[Music]
n
no
[Music]
a
he
[Music]
10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1
Z hi there if you're watching this it's
because you love Halloween and you also
love great big story we wanted to treat
you to a Halloween special from haunted
houses to a very gruesome Chef prepare
to be
spooked
[Music]
well I think any cook loves to hear
that's delicious but it means a lot more
when the food is actually horrific it's
a dead body it's a lung maybe a roadkill
[Music]
rats I'm Janice punon and I'm the food
stylist she come to if you want a
Grizzly little something for your table
what have I done roasted legs peing
style whole bodies edible insects tiny
organs for dead rats edible snails oh
space whales raw of
course first I was an art director in
that agency then I'll caterer a cookbook
author a graphic novelist a sculptor
then a miniaturist Couer and uh writing
did I forget
anything oh I love the Reading part of
the creative process lay back on the
sofa I read as much as possible I just
do a quick sketch to communicate to
everybody the look I'm going for and
narrow the field the kitchen is really
where the sorrow begins that's where
everything that you thought was going to
work out great
doesn't and that is where you really
start to think now what am I going to do
you know what's kind of
yummy nothing like a little raw
hamburger to get
going as a food stylist I get all kinds
of requests from actors who have dietary
restrictions I didn't expect however to
get one from a vampire queen who
wouldn't eat meat what I used was
essentially sweet potato that doesn't
look like meat H maybe I need something
to make it more gummy I'll put a bunch
of glutenous flour in well that's a bit
yellow for meat isn't it so I'll put in
some beets after a couple minutes of the
microwave spinning around what it needs
is a little tiny Flex of fat I use
chopped up rice and just plow that stuff
in oil and that's really going to make
it look
visceral
it's not just edible it's
delicious well one little food item that
we have in a lot of horror movies is um
corn syrup corn syrup with food coloring
in it to make it look like blood a
buckets and buckets and buckets of this
stuff uh get used for TV shows and you
just like pour it on and lick it
off I would say the duct tape of food
styling is oil because a little slick of
oil is going to make anything look as if
it just freshly cooked or it's just
Juicy and
Delicious well fake mold if you want it
to be edible you have to use a Dutch
processed cocoa which is a black powder
spirulina powder icing sugar and white
food coloring you can dust them on your
food and it'll look just like mold furry
but
yummy sometimes I use toothpaste because
it comes in a tube and you just throw it
in your bag
and and that's little Blobs of mold but
people don't like to eat a lot of
toothpaste so there you
go when I looked at the first Hannibal
script I thought wow these people are
crazy mads was the most adventurous he
was kind of annoyed with me the first
day when I didn't serve up real lung
real brain and real liver but then I
knew he was going to be an adventurous
eater so it all cut loose from there our
final scene was to be bedelia's dining
on her own leg the leg was the old go-to
pork it had a marrow bone at the thigh
end and a lamb shank at the ankle end I
felt I had to apologize to Jillian and I
said Jillian I'm sorry I'm made the leg
so big if I had made it the size of your
leg it wouldn't have looked as
impressive she did say oh that's
beautiful which is what you really want
she didn't say oh my leg looks
[Laughter]
good part of Storytelling of course is
that tension especially with horror
where so many of the characters are
psychically there on a knife's edge you
want your food to be on a knife's edge
too you want it to Teeter is it horrible
is it delicious no it's horrible and
[Music]
delicious I think people now are more
afraid of death than they've ever been
because they're not familiar with it
because it seems like this exotic other
if every single person who's ever lived
has died it can't be that bad
right I can't imagine how one wouldn't
be fascinated by Death
[Music]
my name is Joanna ebstein I'm the
creative director and co-founder of The
Morbid Anatomy Museum the name morbid
Anatomy seems to suggest to a lot of
people something more like the American
morbidity Museum in American Horror
Story and so people will come in and be
like where are the dead babies they're
like no we don't we don't have dead
babies here there's two parts in the
museum there's the temporary exhibition
which is always borrowed from different
private collectors and there's this room
we in which is the marbad M library I
think a lot of people who like this this
project are people who had to choose at
a certain point between Art and Science
I always wanted to be a scientist and I
wanted to be an artist so I'm always
interested and Drawn to artifacts from
time periods before those things were
divided up these ideas that death and
Beauty Art and Science cute and horrific
have to be separate when I was a kid I
loved animals and I loved live animals I
loved my cat but also I loved looking at
animals the Natural History Museum or in
no jaran from Malahide my college
friends would call me morbid because I
like to pick up roadkill and preserve
the
Skins I never stopped doing it but I was
cognizant of the fact that people
thought I was a freak really through
starting the museum that's when I really
discovered there are so many more people
like me than I ever
[Music]
suspected Japan's Hashima island has a
for boing presence you might recognize
it this completely uninhabited Island
played home to the villain in James
Bond's Skyfall once a booming coal
mining operation that ended in the 1970s
access is strictly limited but coming
here is like stepping into a time
[Music]
capsule
in the canals of Sochi Milo 2 hours
south of Mexico City is an island with a
tragic and disturbing
[Music]
[Applause]
past La Isa deas munas or the island of
the Dolls is home to more than 2500
mutilated and partially dismembered
dolls
roio Sanchez Santana is the current
caretaker of the island perpetuating his
family stewardship of this mysterious
[Applause]
place
[Music]
jul Sana died in 2001 and it is said
that he drowned the same way the young
tourist did
people believe that the spirits that
haunt the island belong to julan or the
young girl or even the dolls
[Music]
themselves whether you believe in
spirits or not a visit to this island
will surely haunt you well after you've
left
[Music]
Winchester Mystery House in San Jose
California is one of the most haunted
places in
America Winchester Mystery House is a
incredibly unique Victorian Mansion
created by Sarah Winchester arys to the
Winchester repeating arms Fortune Sarah
Winchester had a series of unfortunate
things happened to her including the
death of her husband and daughter
she was a spiritualist and visited a
medium to try and understand why the
medium said well the gun that won the
West there's a lot of karma there so
head West and build a house to appease
these Spirits she started Construction
in 1884 which didn't stop till the day
she died the house is 160 room Victorian
Mansion with no master plan there's a
lot of strange
attributes there's 40 staircases 40
fireplaces four elevators we have a
number of staircases that lead right to
the ceiling doors that open up into
nothing or it's just a wall the house is
known for its spirits who many people
believe are the ghosts of people who
worked at the house or even Sarah
herself a lot of our guests and
employees have had very strange things
happen to them in this house sometimes
it's just footsteps or hearing a voice
the light that flickers or sometimes
it's an actual full physical
manifestation if we haven't solved the
mysteries in 93 years then I don't know
if we ever
will I think like everybody I'm
interested in stories about ghosts or
extraterrestrials some people would say
well don't explain that don't explain
that I want to believe that people call
me a debunker they say I'm trying to
disprove I'm reigning on their parade
and you know what I don't apologize at
all for trying to find the
[Music]
truth and Joe nickel from the committee
for skeptical inquiry we've invited
renowned skeptic Joe nickel to meet cor
Lorenzo this this medieval Superstition
has got to go and and this is really
just just silly except I'm Joe nickel
and I'm a Paranormal Investigator I
investigate everything from Monsters
ghosts aliens psychics for a science
organization and the magazine skeptical
Inquirer I knew at the age of eight that
I was a detective but I eventually
became a stage
magician oh my goodness my models were
Harry Houdini and other magicians who
use their magic talents to expose
trickery and meanwhile like everybody I
was curious about haunted houses and
flying saucers and I decided I wanted to
do something like that I've written
about 40 books primarily on Mysteries a
lot of cases were Miracle claims or some
kind of religious claims spontaneous
human combustion lake monster mysteries
crop circles UFO sighting chupacabras
ghost
[Music]
Bigfoot what I'm trying to do is
actually investigate looking for facts
and clues as as you begin to put
together a case File you fill the file
folder with what data you have and then
trying to find actually corroborative
evidence so that I can try to explain
what's happening explain a UFO sighting
my explanations are often quite
mundane people report seeing these long
necked multi- humped lake monsters there
are many things that can create the
illusion of a lake monster including two
or three or for Otter swimming in line
which create the effect of one large
creature Bigfoot is a tall hairy bipedal
creature there is a creature that looks
very much like Bigfoot that is a black
bear or a brown bear standing sniffing
the air and walking about people driving
by an old mansion in the little
community of Bert New York sometimes
reported seeing a ghostly figure dressed
in white it turns out they had had a
mannequin dressed in white in the window
and that was responsible for many of
those
sightings I I think part of me would
like forther to be ghosts and forther to
be
extraterrestrials but I've done this a
long time and I'm pretty sure that
ghosts don't exist even the Skeptics who
like what I do well often their first
reaction is that's pretty obvious
everything is obvious after it's been
exped
[Music]
people ask me this you know for my day
jump isn't what you do
tedious as a stop motion animator you're
very conscious of time and of
incrementally moving a three-dimensional
object Bit by Bit by Bit Mad God is a
stop motion film that I've been kind of
making for like the last 30 years
there's nothing stopping me from
continuing doing it you know
[Music]
forever when I was 5 years old in
1955 I saw King Kong on television as a
stupid kid I was just enthralled by
Hollywood monsters and that was really
the thing that kind of kindled my
appetite subsequently over the years I
have worn many hats in the motion
picture racket I've been involved with
Star Wars the RoboCop series Jurassic
Park Starship Troopers on and on one of
the things that gives me a lot of
pleasure is is to make something but the
day job has certain requirements to it
over the years those requirements have
become a lot more
limiting the Mad God project allowed me
to just make this more pure thing that
was kind of a form of therapy for me as
an antidote to my day
job it's a combination of liveaction and
stop motion miniature sets in layers
like a collage for lack of a better term
it's a passion project and things keep
getting deeper and darker and
Otter there are imaginary cities that
are built out of iron ingots there's
like strange jungles that you go through
there's this huge dystopic po industrial
nightmare City and it just goes on and
on and on I me practically anything that
I can think of inherent in it there's a
um level of surprise that I I think you
know for me is a very childlike kind of
a thing I shoot here at my studio in
Berkeley it's stocked with all kinds of
stuff for all kinds of different
electronic projects woodworking projects
lights cameras so it's a huge Toy Box
all of the characters in Mad God are
built by me the process begins with the
articulated skeleton and that's made by
Ballin socket or hinge joints that allow
you to move the characters incrementally
one frame at a time and then I just wrap
lengths of polyurethane foam and build
up the general Mass from there I will
take latex skins adhere them with rubber
cement paint the thing and it's ready to
shoot when you're actually shooting a
stop motion scene you project into the
character and sometimes it can get very
complicated you are always gauging
acceleration and deceleration weight and
mass and then that kind of leads to but
you know what what would make it
better for me this whole process is more
of a compulsion I really have no say
over it's just something that I I
I have to do you know I've been doing it
so long it's I I breathe I live and
breathe in this world it's all I think
[Music]
about there's the
rulers the Reverb
tank the
ebo
a normal instrument you're you're
playing it and you're expecting it to
have a sound that is
pleasing but with an instrument like
this the goal is to Just Produce sounds
that in this case are
[Music]
disturbing
the apprehension engine it's an
instrument that creates a variety of
really creepy and some would say
horrifying
sounds my name is Mark Corin I'm a film
music composer and lately I've been
focusing on horror movie
scores two of my biggest hits as far as
horror films are concerned was from the
late '90s a film called Cube
and most recently uh the
[Applause]
witch I originally commissioned the
apprehension engine because I was tired
of the same digital samples which which
resulted in a lot of sameness of a lot
of horror
[Music]
music so I was looking for something
more experimental more acoustic that
would give me a little bit more of an
original
sound that's where I contacted my friend
Tony dougen
[Music]
Smith so Mark called me asking me to
create a crazy instrument for horror
films because I'd never done anything
like that before it made me empty out
all my pockets and all my drawers of any
knickknacks and bits and bobbs I could
possibly string together to make it
happen for him and this is what came of
it
[Music]
you're dealing with things that stir
Primal emotions and
feelings and there actually is a skill
set that you have to acquire in order to
get the most out of
it it expresses what really can't be
expressed any other
way it's not music in the traditional
sense at all but let me put it this way
the apprehension engine definitely
evokes an emotion so I would call it
[Music]
music faces are the most important
subject matter in
art it's a never ending source of
material when you put on one of my masks
you become somebody
different you start to embody that
character and have a lot of fun with
it my name's Landon Meyer and I make
disturbingly realistic
[Music]
masks I never thought thought I was
going to make a living doing masks I was
a picture framer loan officer pizza
delivery driver and then I got laid
off I've always been interested in doing
something that's like really surreal in
nightmarish so it was more or less an
experiment that took
off I the only person out there that's
doing hyperrealistic lightness masks I'm
kind of this weird mad scientist down in
the
[Music]
basement I start off getting lots of
reference
material the hardest part is doing the
sculpture that can take anywhere from 4
days to a year but once the sculpt is
done and I have a mold it's about a onee
process to make a
mask they are ungodly expensive they
range $500 and up and sometimes even
high is
$7,500 over the years I've made
approximately 25 different designs and
I've produced with my own hands over a
thousand
masks what I make I like to consider
wearable art these are super realistic
sculptures you can put over your head
and
wear people just seem to have this
astonished reaction to the MK
that's what I love about
[Music]
him this great big story was made
possible by Wells Fargo established 1852
reestablished
2018 when it comes to horror movies
there's an actor who is so good at his
job his performances stay with you like
a nightmare you just can't wake up from
but trust us he's a a really nice
guy could you give us a club let's go
I'm Javier about and I'm an actor and
Javier's been in a lot of movies you
probably just didn't see him because
well he looks quite different most of
the time I feel very comfortable in
Monster rols I've been in it Mama
country two green some big Slender Man
and let's not forget he's been in the
mummy and alien too I'm very skinny I'm
2 m tall and
56 kg it's not a problem of eating
because I love to eat it's a personal
condition is call it Maran
syndrome Javier's career started when he
met a prosthetic makeup teacher in
Madrid this led to Javier's first
Monster role in the movie Beneath Still
Waters that was my first makeup my first
work in a
real movie and well after that all the
makeup artists start seeing my work and
start proposing me in other roles the
last year I've been working in eight or
or nine different shows there's got to
be some behind the scenes gossip then
yeah well I I was in Crimson Peak I was
out of all the makeup and I was the last
day with G Toro and I say Tom Kon and I
said okay see was a pleasure and he said
who who are you so I say I was your
Ex-Wives oh okay okay yeah sorry I
didn't recognize you but don't pigeon
hole this guy he might be a monster most
of the time but he's got dramatic range
okay guys you ready really love what you
do cuz it's going to be hard and long
journey be prepared you never know
what's going to happen don't be shy
don't let the fear paralyze you
so
relax you know what I mean
w if I can ask for something I love I
would love to be a a big Sith I will
rule the
[Music]
galaxy that's amazing that's amazing
thank
you
[Music]
once a town of nearly 10,000 Bodhi is
located just east of the Sierra Nevada
mountain range in
California established in 1859 as a gold
mining Village at its height there were
nearly 2,000 buildings
here now 200 remain as this town lies in
a state of Arrested
Decay bodh is one of the most
well-preserved ghost towns in America
[Music]
America
[Applause]
[Music]
in the northwest region of Cambodia
there's a site like none other where
trees rise from rooftops and Roots snake
their way through walls this this is tap
prom a 12th century Buddhist temple
that's become one with the
[Music]
jungle
deep in the namibian desert is a place
Time
Forgot once a German Colony miners
flocked here after diamonds were
discovered in 1908 the town grew quickly
fueled by the enormous
wealth hidden beneath the
Sands but as the diamonds disappeared
and production relocated the town was
left completely
abandoned to be slowly consumed by the
ever shifting desert
[Music]
we've tapped into the radios we can
confirm two divisions confirmed you have
an aerial visual copy yes yes we can
hear them moving in only none of what
the Germans thought they could see or
hear was
real during World War II a secret
division of the US Army now known as the
ghost Army conducted over 20 tactical
operations which resulted in Saving tens
of thousands of lives the mission to
trick the enemy into thinking that their
unit of 1,000 men was actually two
divisions of 30,000 men but the ghost
Army wasn't made up of traditional
Soldiers the majority were actors
designers advertisers and artists who
had been recruited from the top Art and
Design schools around the country and
this Army of artists use their
creativity for an infantry of
Illusion Engineers develop veloped
inflatable tanks which the artists would
then paint these tanks could condense
down to fit into a portable bag and
inflate on demand much like a bouncy
[Music]
castle audio Engineers used large
speakers to play sound effects of tanks
and marching soldiers which had been
pre-recorded at Fort Knox this marching
Army could be heard from Miles Away
along with fake radio messages sent into
the signals of the enemies they would
also send actors dressed as generals and
off officers into local towns to spread
false information and rumors it wasn't
until 1996 when information about the
ghost Army was Declassified that the
world finally knew about these masters
of misdirection the unsung heroes of
World War
[Music]
II a Tropa Belladonna will kill
you theur will put you to sleep forever
aanm will kill you Laurel will produce
Cyanide and kill
you every plant here in the poison
garden is poisonous and has the ability
to kill
you my name is Trevor Jones and I'm the
head Gardener of anic garden this plant
is giant hogweed it will get up to
around about 8T High it's phototoxic so
will burn your skin and give you
blisters for up to 7 years this Garden
is set in the wall Garden of the old
castle in Northumberland UK we' have
around about 95 plants and we're adding
to the collection all the time this
plant is aconitum or monks Hood
wonderful blue flowers but the whole of
the plant is poisonous the berries
crushed up and fed to you will kill you
the leaves themselves will kill you also
as will the root and the stem we have to
obviously maintain the garden so we have
to tend the plants and when we do that
we have to be very careful of the way we
operate so we have to cover some of our
skin when we deal with particularly
dangerous
plants this plant is Lal it produces
Cyanide and we all know what that will
do to you so it was the brain chart of
The Duchess the duess of Northland so
rather than having a herb garden she
decided to create more interest and have
a poison garden they're very very common
plants in fact a lot of them are what we
call Cottage Garden plants and they're
grown in many people's Gardens but
people don't know how harmful they
actually
are this is a trop of Belladonna four
berries are enough to kill a
child people are intrigued by poisonous
plants and often very worried when they
come out because many of them will be
growing these plants at home they don't
realize the powerful impact plants can
have on us as
humans is it something that you find
fascinating definitely why uh it's a
good way to get rid of your
life
I don't
[Music]
know the Loch Ness Monster is one of our
most enduring
myths people have SED secrets for over
1500 years but only one man has devoted
his entire life to learning the
truth alone in a van by the
lock
and no he's not a wacko it's just his
[Music]
thing my name is Steve falam and for the
last 25 years I've been a full-time
Hunter of the Loess
monster I first came to less when I was
a 7-year-old boy and found this set of
Caravans with this gang of grown men
hunting for monsters in L nest and I I
thought that's amazing that would be the
life for me I'd love to do that and so
he did 25 years ago he quit his job sold
his house bought this van and pursued
his passion he now holds the Guinness
record for the longest continuous search
at Loch
[Music]
Ness in all my time here I've only seen
one possible sighting of
something all you saw was a spray of
water off of the back of something buff
buff buff buff buff Like a Torpedo going
shooting through to this day that
remains a mystery to me as to what that
was that was in the first year of being
here and I thought right this job's
going to be really easy that's one
sighting 25 years later I'm still sat
here waiting for that second
sighting some people think it's giant
eels some people think there's a ripping
time time others believe there's a
spaceship on the bottom of the
Lo it's more likely to turn out to be
big catfish than a spaceship on the
bottom of the
lock the reason I sit here and I try and
solve this mystery is because that's
what makes my heart
sing people say is it lifestyle or is it
the
mystery it's both my life contains
Freedom Adventure
unpredictability and the chance of one
of the world's greatest discoveries
should I ever happen to find
Nessie it's a dream come true if that
little seven-year-old boy could see what
became of him he wouldn't believe his
[Music]
luck the Redwood Forest is a very
special
place it's the darkest Forest on
Earth the trees are so tall they create
their own shadows and in those Shadows
there are a lot of
[Music]
Secrets my name is Dave cuy I'm a dosent
here at Henry cow Redwood State Park I
consider myself kind of a volunteer
naturalist and Redwood researcher before
coming to Henry C I was a engineer in
Silicon Valley but I just loveed the
Redwoods I've always been an outdoor
kind of person I've been coming here for
40 years I come so often now I I I swear
I could almost tell when a single Branch
fell these are the coastal redwood
Sequoia sea verin it is the tallest tree
on Earth by
species their wood is very very
interesting it's red in color it's very
complex genetically and you can have
some that are not like all the
others albino redwoods have been called
ghost of the
forest we have found 13 albinos in this
park and not very many not when you
consider there's 2 million redwood trees
out
there I really know albinos I know where
they all are and I continue to look for
more albino redwoods have a very very
soft nature they they aren't as
structurally sound as a normal Redwood
and we keep trying to understand why
they form here when we first started uh
looking at these things we said okay
they're genetically different but it
could be contamination so we have done
some testing found that these guys
actually collect more nickel than these
guys nickel would normally kill
chlorophyll but the albino Redwood
doesn't have any chlorophyll so it
doesn't hurt it at
all so where's the source of nickel well
we're on a
railroad some researchers think it is
acting like a a liver filtering out the
the toxic components protecting the rest
of the
[Music]
forest when I first started here I
started telling everybody where they
were and then I started finding pieces
of albino Redwood on the ground people
would go and touch and fold and break
off pieces and I realized that I
couldn't do that I could not be open
with people because they were going to
go in and destroy it so their location
has been kept
secret redwoods are a treasure of the
earth they really
are and the more you study them the more
you realize how unique they are and how
adaptable they are part of the
fascination of the Redwood Forest is its
diversity I am continuing to be
fascinated by what I
see
[Music]
it starts with a yes or no question does
she have a crush on me will I pass the
test will the Mets win the World Series
well they may not have always predicted
the truth magic eight balls are actually
inspired by a real life
Clairvoyant do you want to hear your
fortune in the 1940s Mary Carter was a
popular Med best known for her
mysterious fortunetelling invention it
was called the psycho slate essentially
a chalkboard with a cover when the
clients would visit Mary would ask a
question to the spirits the room would
fill with the sound of scribbling and
then just like Poof Magic Mary would
reveal answers from another world
mysteriously written on the chalkboard
Mary's son Albert was inspired by his
mother and created his own truth-seeking
device but this time you didn't need a
psychic to tell you your
fortune he put a pair pair of worded
dice inside a tube filled with molasses
each end was clear so you could read the
answers sound familiar Albert hit the
streets he partnered with a couple local
businessmen and opened a Novelty Company
where they specialized in the miracle
home fortune teller after he died
Albert's Partners took over and
redesigned the project numerous times
they ended up with a crystal ball like
shape with a D in the middle and a
Billiards company took note they needed
a promotional item so they replaced the
crystal ball with the iconic black eight
ball
the promotion was so successful that
they rebranded the magic eightball this
time marketing it as a fortunetelling
toy today kids are still using magic
eight balls to ask for their fortunes
and for that you can thank Mary The
Clairvoyant ah
yes Goosebumps is one of the bestselling
book series of all time and this man is
responsible for each and every
terrifying spine tingling horror filled
story hi I'm RL Stein I write the
Goosebumps books huh maybe he's not so
scary I actually started as a humor
writer well what do you
know in 1992 Scholastic released the
very first Goosebumps book but way
before that a young Bob Stein was into
writing jokes I started writing funny
stuff when I was 9 years old all I ever
wanted to be was fun
when I came to New York I had my own
Humor Magazine and after 10 years I
thought gee I've done what I always
wanted to do I guess I'll Coast the rest
of my life I had no idea what was in
store for me and then things started to
get spooky I had lunch with the
editorial director at Scholastic she'd
had a fight with a ya horror writer and
she said you could write a good ya
horror novel said okay no problem you
got it and I went home and wrote this
novel and it was a number one bestseller
I thought whoa wait a minute forget the
funny stuff and I've been scary ever
since that book marked the start of RL
Stein's horror writing career and he
eventually wrote an entire series called
Goosebumps but it wasn't an immediate
success they went out and they just sat
on the shelves they didn't sell 2 months
goes by 3 months nothing we figured
that's it didn't work work out and then
something happened it's a mystery kids
discovered it somehow nobody knew me
really there was no hype no advertising
no publicity there was nothing just kids
telling kids it's just you know one of
these amazing lucky things that happened
now after 25 years Goosebumps is scaring
a whole new generation of kids it's a
really nice thing to be able to write
for different Generations at first I was
shocked when adults started sh showing
up in my book signings I say what are
you doing here said we loved you when we
were kids and I
realized I'm Nostalgia to them I think
you kind of remember that tingle of fear
that you had when you were a kid but
with the success of Goosebumps does ARL
Stein ever miss the chance to be funny
there's something weird with my brain
because horror always makes me laugh
it's that same visceral reaction that's
what I try to do in my books people
think if you're a horror writer you're
scary all the time and your whole life
is horror but I did my own late night uh
comedy show at Upright Citizens Brigade
last year are you doing one this year
too I'm waiting by the phone no one's
called me I don't know I'm
waiting that was it that might be my
comedy
[Music]
career
normally there's this awkwardness around
disability but with that costume on
there that changed how people saw my son
they saw him first before they saw his
disability it just helps break down that
barrier magic wheelchair is a nonprofit
that builds epic costumes for amazing
kiddos and
wheelchairs
magic wheelchair started when my son was
3 years old Halloween rolled around and
he wanted to be a pirate we're new to
the whole disabilities and wheelchair
thing we didn't know anything about
spinal muscular
atrophy I saw him sitting in his
wheelchair and thought w we could dress
him up as a pirate be a pirate in a
wheelchair and let's let's build a
ship we have made probably about four 40
different costumes we have teams right
now all over the country we have a team
in France and working on a team in
Australia we're just going to keep
onboarding teams cuz we want to build
year
round it's hard to build for people that
are in wheelchairs but It ultimately
starts with the kid it's whatever they
want to be and then we make it a
[Music]
reality
Halloween was kind of our initial push
but we're seeing like Comic-Con
right and what's cool about that
community of Cosplay that's a very
supportive
Community the the cold reality of
childhood diseases are some of them
won't be around for next Halloween so
let's find something that we can do
while they're here with us so they have
these that they have these great
memories and that
their their families have memories when
they're
gone it's almost like a cure for the day
cuz they don't see the wheelchair they
just see these amazing kids and it
Bridges gaps and
overcomes that awkwardness that we have
in
society I mean they star the show oh
it's awesome to
[Music]
see
every night countless people wake up
unable to move their minds and bodies in
the throws of a real condition called
sleep
paralysis when triggered the symptoms
are usually mild from tense muscles to
labored breathing but for some The
Experience conjures hallucinations that
make Nightmares come alive here are some
of their
stories
uh before I learn to cope with it I've
seen quite a few awful things horror
films don't really they don't really do
anything for me anymore because what
I've seen is more
terrifying the earliest I can remember
is seeing a figure that looked like my
mother sitting on my bed uh her face is
then morphing into some kind of demon
and other time a little girl was in the
corner just just staring at me then
without notice she shrieks and runs up
and grabs me by the
neck you try to call for help but your
voice it uh it doesn't work and your
body um won't respond you just you just
you just feel
helpless on one particular night I felt
like someone was looking at me from the
foot of my bed I knew that that nothing
was there but I was afraid to open my
eyes when I did I saw a woman's head
looking straight back at me she didn't
have a body or even a neck just her head
I still remember the smirk she had on
her
face I closed my eyes immediately and I
was unable to
move when I felt it was safe I open my
eyes
again
[Music]
she was still there and she began to
laugh at
me I closed my eyes again hoping she
would
disappear then I heard this
scoff and she was
gone so I remember waking up and feeling
a presence in in the room and I See This
Woman in a Black Dress looming above the
floor and she kept coming closer and
closer to me I could feel my throat
closing and I I couldn't
breathe as soon as she made it towards
me she floated right in front of my face
and started
[Applause]
screaming I bolted out of my bed and I
tried to wake up my parents little did I
know I was still dreaming and I ended up
back in my bed in another sleep
paralysis experience it's something that
so wild and surreal that there's no
logic to
it so if you wake up one day Paralyzed
by horrific Visions remember to stay
calm and understand that your nightmares
are only as real as you make
[Music]
them in Guana Mexico there is a museum
filled entirely with
[Music]
mummies with 117 bodies in total the
museum has the largest collection of
natural mummies in the
world the mummies are the well-preserved
remains of people who died during a
chalera outbreak in Mexico in the
1800s the museum is a haunting and Eerie
experience for visitors an opportunity
to stare death in the
[Music]
face
thanks so much for watching guys we hope
you had a really spooky time watching
our Halloween live stream special make
sure to check out some of our other
videos down below and from everyone here
at GBS we hope you have a really scary
Halloween
[Music]
bye